Ronan Farrow says Matt Lauer is quote
just wrong Pharaoh is speaking out about
accusations Lauer made about him in an
op-ed on Tuesday the former Morning Show
anchor made several claims about the
accuracy of Pharaoh's book caption kill
Pharaoh took to Twitter and wrote all
I'll say on this is that Matt Lauer is
just wrong catch and kill was thoroughly
reported and fact checked including with
Matt Lauer himself in regards to
Pharaohs reporting about NBC related
stories flowers said Ferrell was quote
hardly an unbiased journalist Pharaoh's
book included a detailed accusation
against Lauer from former NBC employee
Brooke novels nevels claimed that Lauer
raped her while they were both working
for NBC at the 2014 Winter Olympics in
Sochi
nevels described later sexual encounters
with Lauer as quote transactional and
claimed that she only consented out of
fear that Lauer had control over her
career flower later admitted to a
consensual relationship with nevels but
has denied the rape allegations nevels
has yet to directly respond to Lauer but
she seemingly referenced his comments in
a tweet on Tuesday she wrote Darbo deny
attack reverse victim and offender Lauer
also claimed that Pharaoh failed to
provide important evidence in the
allegation against him and that the
accusation from nevels was purposefully
used to promote the release of catch and
kill flower concluded the op-ed with in
the meantime I will continue to ask
questions and seek answers because
ironically I can thank Ronan for at
least one thing he has reminded me how
it feels to do the work I love
[Music]